when we do finally get a new stargate
series i think i know the perfect
protagonist
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so we all know the difference between a
good show and a great show is a great
bad guy
if stargate is to succeed they need a
good bad guy and i think i have the
perfect candidate
the furlings
we thought we'd never get to meet you
i thought i could make it work the
thermodynamic loop is feeding back into
the planet's core
[Music]
well that never happened now we don't
know much about the furlings even though
jack o'neill's convinced they look like
the ewoks
beyond the fact that they were a member
of the first four races that set up an
alliance against the gold world we don't
know a great deal about them we've seen
episodes where it was rumored that we
met them we saw episodes where it was
rumored they built the touchstone for
example the weather control device
we know that they built a utopian
community in the episode paradise lost
in a gold snooker chemical weapon in
there that made them all kill themselves
other than that in episodes like grace
we don't know a great deal about them
now the fact that they are a complete
mystery compared to the knox the asgard
and obviously the ancients i think makes
them a really interesting um target to
make the main protagonist of a new
series
also they could come in like a good guy
and something happens in their twist or
we could see a faction of the furlings
maybe that that come in and have an
agenda that we
for whatever reason need to go and fight
them against but the main reason why i
think the feelings would be a really
interesting protagonist other than the
fact that we'd love to know more about
them is that an enemy for the new series
has to be more advanced or more
terrifying than something we've seen
before so we had the gold the
replicators
the wraith and the aura and the sgc
defeated them all
so what do we have next well obviously
one of the original four great races
would make a really interesting bad guy
but also it wouldn't just be a bad guy
because they're evil there would have to
be some sort of storyline to explain why
they'd become the protagonist why they'd
become a threat
because obviously they were an ally of
the asgard the ancients and the knox so
what happened to them that turned them
into an enemy
i think situations like maybe paradise
lost episode where they had a utopian
society where they allowed people to
join them in peace with no weapons but
then were slaughtered maybe that's one
of the reasons that turned them or
changed their thinking in some way that
makes them an enemy in the future i'm
thinking sort of like where the vorlands
were considered our allies but then
turned out to be an enemy towards the
end of babylon 5.
or how say
in
the mcu you've got bad guys that aren't
evil they've always got a reason like
the kingpin and daredevil he had a
reason for what he was doing he didn't
think of himself as the bad guy he
thought of himself as making tough
choices the obvious one of that is also
thanos he didn't consider himself the
bad guy he thought he was saving the
half that was left rather than worrying
about the fact that he was killing the
half that he um
vape priced
another interesting part maybe would be
if this was just a faction of the
furlings somebody you know because at
the end of the day no species is the
same look at humanity we all have
different cultures different societies
maybe it's just a small part of the
feelings that we're having to contend
with and the rest of the feelings are
actually our peace loving still and kind
maybe the feelings did actually all
ascend and a small group of them decided
to return for some reason maybe it's as
simple as they've decided that there's
too much evil and too much violence in
the universe and that they're going to
return to our galaxy to sort us all out
like angry parents punishing the
children but what do you think about my
idea about making the furlings the
protagonist in a new series or would you
prefer to have something completely new
completely different an enemy we'd never
heard of before
get in the comments tell me exactly what
you think also if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit that
bell notification it really helps us out
also if you enjoy the content please
consider hitting that join button and
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
and as always please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you